if it came down to Nikki Hurley vers Joe
Biden which way would you lean on there
seems to be an interesting thing
happening with Nikki right now where
there's two kind of schools of thought
one is that she can bring in new voters
so here's Kaylee mckinn who used to she
was like The Shining Star of the of the
Trump presidency uh he subsequently has
turned on her but she said uh Nikki
Haley just congratulated Trump her
opponent on his win interesting she has
made clear that she is not running for
second but still is clearly a strong
Contender for Vice president politics is
a game of addition and Nikki adds a
different voting block to Trump's base
that seems very true to me like I know
the bass doesn't want to hear it but
first off they have worked together she
was US ambassador to the UN under Trump
she did a pretty damn good job at it I
know the Bas hates like the whatever the
neocon stuff they try to attach to her
is um but he is going to have to figure
out some way to bring in some new people
right yes I mean I wouldn't read too
much into Kaye mcenany's tweet with all
dues to Kaye she was his press secretary
and not his chief of staff she didn't
run his campaign she was was his
mouthpiece for like a year uh and now
she's at Fox News where they're very
much behind Haley so like I wouldn't
read too deeply into that now is it out
of the realm of possibility that he
chooses Haley absolutely not it's not I
realized that Maga doesn't want it
they've convinced themselves that Nikki
Haley is is against all the things that
they stand for in particular the new
isolationist strain um within the
Republican party she's the opposite
she's more of a neocon that's why the
folks over at common
and Summit National Review although
they're they're I think a little bit
more Pro to sandis but in any event
that's why they like her um but Trump
has to win Dave Trump must win he has no
choice for himself and I think he thinks
America needs him to win but he he
personally really must win if he doesn't
want to go to jail it now that it's
going to be Trump and he doesn't have to
rely on another rep Republican to Pardon
him or pull the doj off of him he's
going to have to do it he if he doesn't
win now if he's the Republican nominee
he's going to jail and not just like
going to jail and then having an appeal
he's probably going to jail and is going
to stay in jail for a long time
potentially for the rest of his life so
if that's your
situation I think you might be thinking
mag is gonna get over Niki Haley if I
tell them to get over Nikki Haley I mean
I know for a fact that's how Trump
thinks Maga feels the way I tell them to
feel Y and he's probably thinking if if
he want her they'll get they'll get past
it they're not going to sit at home and
not come out for me and they're not
going to watch me lose to Joe Biden
potentially getting him and or kamla
Harris in the next five years as their
president so I'll take that risk because
I need moderates and I need Independence
I don't need somebody to help me with
conservatives like I did eight years ago
he needed Mike Pence you know Trump had
always been a Democrat right that was
one of my debate questions for him how
long how long have you been a republican
back because it he didn't sound like one
he hadn't been living as one it seemed
like a recent thing he had picked up
after watching Fox News for two years so
he needed Pence now he needs something
different needs to convince moderates
and Democrats he's not The Devil he's
not going to do a six-week abortion ban
the things that drive Dems to the poll
polls so it does make some sense I I
could not agree more I I when I see all
these people that are suddenly like no
he'll never do it and or I won't vote
for him if he chooses Nikki it's like
you'll do what Trump kind of tells you
to do actually that's a perfect segue so
Tucker who seems to be in that camp
basically I think he said if I'm not
mistaken he would not vote for Donald
Trump if TR ifp against campaign against
him even further take a look at this
next week estimates suggest that 40%
maybe more of all primary voters in the
Republican primary will not be
Republicans so who who will they be well
they'll be liberals like this one yeah
I'm still undecided on who I'm voting
for I am a Democrat um but I think um I
think Biden's too old to be in office
and I watched the Republican debate and
I think Haley I definitely don't agree
with a lot of her platform but I think
she has a lot of a mention behind her
and I think she's much more capable than
both Trump and Biden wow you mentioned
that you're a Democrat said Joe Biden's
a little bit too old if it came down to
Nikki Hurley vers Joe Biden which way
would you lean then I think I'm still
undecided on that I definitely agree a
lot more with Biden's platform but I
think Haley's more capable of the job
that poor girl she'll be embarrassed by
that tape at some point but she went on
in in that video to explain that the
issues that she cares most about in the
world are quote climate and
transgenderism so that's where she is
politically and if Nikki Haley wins the
primary next week it will be because of
people like the woman you you just saw
they are the real Nikki Haley
voters okay Megan I don't want to make
it about that girl who's just randomly
showing up there and whatever let's just
put her aside for a moment uh but the
the notion that if Trump chose Nikki
that Tucker Carlson would actively
campaign against him I mean that's
pretty
intense I guess I have my doubts about
whether Tucker would really do it I
accept that ex doesn't want her at all
but you know in the end the politics
it's a binary Choice there you know yes
you might have RFK J or you might have
you know Joe Mansion but Tucker's not
going to vote for one of them he's I
think he's going to come home to Trump I
think he's going to do it under protest
I think he's going to look for ways to
limit her influence that kind of thing
and listen he'll have more influence
over Donald Trump than Nikki Haley well
I don't think the influence will go two
ways between Nikki and Joe Biden I mean
sorry Nikki and Donald Trump yeah um I
really think he'll he'll tell her what
to do and she's not going to influence
him at
all I don't really believe it I think
it's one of those things where it's like
I'm taking my ball and I'm going home
but like the game is so fun and you
really don't want your team to lose so
you will play that's that's my
bet